if you were to describe halos
traditional multiplayer as a house party
a small gathering of friends and
strangers for an evening of laughs and
heroics inhaler fight a new war zone
mode is more like a festival you are
still surrounded by the same sights and
sounds and halo signature style of
combat is as unmistakable as ever put on
war zone you are free to choose where to
spend your time and where to concentrate
your fire power right now you're looking
at the world first reveal of the raid on
apex 7 level in one section of this
sprawling open world map you could for
example be busy mowing down hordes of
Covenant AI on the opposite side of the
island you might find teammates
assembling a warthog gearing up for some
four-player drive-bys in one of the
command posts you could find a three-way
skirmish between both human teams and
the AI and on another you might
encounter a legendary elite boss
patrolling the area waiting for someone
foolish enough to cross its path how all
these different attractions come
together under single gold is what makes
war zone the most unique and interesting
addition to the Halo series in years the
overarching objective is for your team
of 12 Spartans to accumulate a thousand
points before your opponents do how this
is done is your choice you can for
example and a single point by killing
someone on the opposing team or you
could triple in a stream of points by
controlling one of the maps basis or you
could add 25 points for taking out an
elite a I or if you manage to kill a
legendary boss you can earn a
game-changing a hundred and fifty points
a single game of war zone can typically
last up to 30 minutes teams frantically
try to cross the finish line but there's
also a backdoor path to victory each war
zone map features three bases the
players can occupy a patine manages to
control all three bases at the same time
their opposing teams based core is then
exposed if that teams core is destroyed
regardless of what score they have
lose the match it means that you can
still snatch victory from the jaws of
defeat even if lagging behind by 700
points how these gameplay goals clash
and trip into one another makes war zone
particularly chaotic and unpredictable
at times here you can see me fighting to
covenant elders these hulking AI pose
with devastating melee attacks
overcoming them demands high levels of
concentration and here just as I got
into the right rhythm suddenly I was
attacked while you're posing team plans
had to be abandoned it's a degree of
fluctuation the tremendous sense of war
at scale and the sheer breadth of
options that makes war zone such an
exciting prospect all this may suggest
war zone is prohibitively complex but
it's actually accommodating for all
kinds of players especially casual your
spawn points are well protected and
those who aren't particularly skilled
can if they wish just concentrate on
taking down AI these players can add to
the final score as much as the killed
streaking veterans can in fact everyone
can bring something to war zone those
who aren't the most skilled marksman can
charge up score tallies just by
occupying basis even the thrill seekers
who want to leap onto Covenant ghosts
madly stick a grenade on the engine and
dash away just before the bomb goes off
are still in their own mad little way
adding to the total score seasoned
veterans of course will want to be doing
all these things Microsoft wants war
zone to a massive vast community of
players not split apart the way halo 4
said being after the premium DLC arrived
which is why war zones 50 maps will be
free however in place of the DLC is
micro transactions which allows players
to buy more powerful and exotic vehicles
and weapons so a couple of caveats first
you can still earn currency by grinding
second each weapon essentially has a
manner school which in Halo is called a
wreck
clever each warzone game starts at rec
level one and only in the late game can
players start using the most powerful
weapons they have purchased it's not
quite pay to win but casual players with
cash to burn will have an undeniable
advantage over casual have-nots whether
that advantage will extend over to the
hardcore players however remains to be
seen microtransaction worries aside
warzone could very well be the most
interesting thing to happen to Halo and
indeed multiplayer shooters for quite
some time it comes bundled with halo 5
guardians which ships worldwide on a
favor 27 stay tuned to gamespot for the
review
you